Hey, this is a funny one. A Fox News had a
sort of town hall with, or an audience of
law enforcement and first responders and it
went horribly wrong when not a single one
of them may be one person in the audience
was willing to validate the entire war on
cops narrative that Fox News has been pushing
for years. This is hilarious. And when it
happens, it actually happened during the Bernie
Sanders town hall on Fox News a few months
ago. I'll tell you about that in a second
if you've forgotten about it. But first let's
take a look at a clip or Fox News tries to
expose the violent, evil, anti-police leftist
by saying, put your hands up if you've had
liquids thrown at you or been heckled or disrespected
or whatever and maybe one hand goes up. It
might've been someone just trying to say they
needed to get up to go to the bathroom. Truly,
truly awkward. Take a look at this.
You know what? The conversation in this country
has really changed. Do you have lawmakers
that are going to restaurants? They're harassed
with their families and they have to think,
okay, wife, husband, how do we prepare for
this? If we get into this situation, you have
firefighters, you have, uh, police officers
on the street. They have to think, what do
we do when this happened? How did we get to
that place? I don't know. Look at the, look
at the post. New York Post says, cow dare
you calling these men and these women that
are doing this, throwing water, throwing them.
Palo was president. Trump stands up and says,
I'm for the taxpayers and the citizens and
the people who came here legally, right? It
resonates so much with people because you
see another side of the island entire Party
saying, we're the party of illegality. We're
the party of, of non citizenship. And he says,
now once last time I checked, America still
matters, right? Can we see the hands of the
people here today, the first responders in
law enforcement who have encountered anything
like that in the last year or so in New York
or wherever you are with water, hit with milk,
disrespected, taunted, or no, anyone that
has, well, that's good. All right, well let's
talk. Let's talk a little bit about just generally
who would like to talk on TV right now. I
would imagine everybody,
another swing and a miss. Again, there was
one guy sort of in the back row who kind of
seemed like he was raising a finger. I don't
know if he was just getting a fly away from
him, but again, the narrative failing and
this is one of those tired old narratives
that the right wing media tries to push in
reaction to stories about police killing unarmed
black teens and black men. The real war is
against police and the real problem they want
us to believe is that the left hates public
servants and law enforcement. The truth is,
let's just step aside from the partisanship.
We have a country of 340 million people. We
can find anecdotal examples of everything.
You can at the same time have examples of
police behaving badly who should be held to
account for it, but mostly police departments
made up of good people trying to do the right
thing.
And I think that that's what we have. You
can at the same time have examples of Antifa
or whoever, treating law enforcement poorly
and attacking them and they should be held
to account. But mostly we have a population
that by and large respects police and treats
them well. This is not shocking and there
was a very similar backfire when Fox News
anchors during the Bernie Sanders, Fox News
town hall, they asked the room who would really
give up their for-profit employer linked health
insurance for a government program. No one
would do that, right? And basically the entire
room's hands went up and they cheered. Remember
this,
I want to ask the audience a question. If
you could raise your hand here a show of hands
of how many people get their insurance from
work private insurance right now. How many
get it from private insurance? Okay. Now of
those, how many are willing to transition
to what the senator says? A government run
system.
[inaudible]
Whoa, whoa. We can't be having that. Another
one of these hilarious backfires that just,
it allows the tiniest bit of reality into
the prevailing Fox News narrative and it can
convince a few people. Now, if you really
want to see a tax on first responders, to
go back to what Fox News is talking about,
if you want to see attacks on the military,
on public servants and government employees,
look at the Oval Office. Look no further than
Donald Trump. I cannot think of any president
that has gone after the FBI prisoners of war,
gold star families, intelligence analysts,
diplomats, public servants more than Donald
Trump has. It's another example of projection,
plain and simple, and isn't it delightful
to see it backfire in the faces of Fox News
anchors that we have come to a see, try this
stuff again and again and again over the years.
I think it's a a great to see and it does
hopefully help to pierce at least a few people's
echo chambers and filter bubbles. Make sure
you're following the David Pakman show on
Instagram at David Pakman show. While you
are there, follow me on Instagram at David
[inaudible]
dot pacman updates from my garden coming up
later today, possibly breaking news contained
there
for sure.